how much were you involved
on finding out you know even have an
insider
uh a scoop on what happened with the
iranian revolution there's a lot of
different stories when they talk about
the
overthrowing of mohammed
pahlavi and how right after the dinner
with carter he leaves in
77 december 31st they you know toast
and he leaves and almost the riots to
protesting the revolution begins
and then 13 months later a little over
13 months later
he's in exile and he's out and iran gets
you know turned over to khomeini
and things change a lot and there's a
lot of different speculation on what
what took place you know whether it was
the you know the 25-year
uh uh contract of oil that was coming up
you know the consort consortium
agreement of 1954 between iran germany
us
uk and i think france and they had the
secret meeting saying let's get him to
uh dethrone him you know there's some
tensions with what was going on with
other reasons for
carter and iran there's a lot of
different stories that you hear about
but that's something with something
that's close to me because i grew and
i've
had a lot of different talks with people
that were directly involved in that but
i'm curious to hear from you because if
you were involved 64
to 96 78 79 and
you guys trained a lot of the savage
that came to you for training there's
got to be some kind of a
story or uh uh you know or even
factual reasons that you have on why
iran
fell because they were doing fine it's
not like they weren't doing good they
were expanding and all of a sudden they
had to fall
what do you think was the reason behind
it you know there is a
we have a saying that a man is close to
himself
in the in the sense that i can give you
my personal experience
um you you didn't mention
the fact that i spent two and a half
years in iran uh in person
me and my young
and beloved wife uh since
since the beginning of 1966
to the summer of 68
um a relatively long time
before the revolution
in in eon but
i can tell you for instance that
and and we we we spend time mainly in
the south
abaddon
those places and
i cannot forget that
uh prior to
each and every memorial day
to the sacrifice of
the shiites prophets
hassan and hussain
the the the government
called the foreign
people who lived at that time in iran
and they asked the foreigners please
remain in your houses during those days
of
uh memorial and i remember that
when i faced this
unique unique
phenomenon because i didn't
i was i was not exposed to uh to this
kind of uh
events before
i asked as i remember asking myself
the question hey
how how is it going to uh
to uh end towards where
this this religious
uh a effecto really
will develop and
jumping from 66 7 and 8
towards the uh um
70s and the end of the 70s
we and i i'm i'm speaking now generally
in general terms
our evaluation was that iran
going towards a revolution of the change
of the
regime we share this we share this
information with
with our american partners
i can remind you that at that time the
american
ambassador was the helms the guy who
who later on became the director of the
cia as well as much as i can
recall it
the americans have not accepted
our evaluations
and why is it so because the
the americans and other foreigners well
were
exposed to the military capabilities
of iran their evaluation was that
the shah was pretty much
ready and capable to cope
with any attempt of a
revolution he was ready ready
i mean already militarily okay
in the military the one
the one point which uh
which no one at that time at least
at least among the uh the intelligence
circle
was that
what's going to be the attitude of uh
president carlton and as i put together
all the pieces
[Music]
the shah waited
for president carter to note with his
head
like this and the
cartel didn't didn't do it not only did
he do it he expressed his of
his objection to
any military
step supposedly taken
by uh by the shah so if you like this
sort of short club from an interview i
did click over here to watch the entire
interview and please don't forget to
subscribe to the channel
take care everybody bye